these offers coming in a Peter Rosa said  dunno it was all ball see the lack of  flexibility a little bit in that wrist  dedicate so much time to get the better  rehab don't forget about us mortgages  half that report come out the 2009  ceremonies honoring  [Applause]  see how physically pushing off the  screens cushion blows out  bounce pass security  it says your pitch is 50 continue to  play the witty huntin yoghurts gonna  take another three no it's gonna go over  an assortment of tricks does he need  yeah he does he has it back it's good  great shot blockers in trouble arm  thanks Dan shovel you cut that body it  takes away for you I believe that jump  and concessions yo get into the lane  basket counts as yoke it's the trailer  picks it up under the park  I believe eight of those are freezers  you  [Applause]